um this is
I'm going to talk about proofs on
Quantum race contractual connotations
this is a joint lock with takasia Makara
from NTT go to university
all details please see this paper
first I explain what is groups of
content
so we have a cross-colored polymer type
Aries and also a boat
mobile wants to show that he has a
quantum computer two eyes
so Aris asks mother to prove it
because iris is crashical they can
exchange only crash colored messages
approval contact yes requires the
following two properties
first are correctness
which means that there exists are
quantum polynomial such that the
probability that our success is a very
large
second the soundness which means that
for any classical polynomial time ball
the probability that our success is
negligibly small
let me explaining the fast construction
of peripheral condoms by this paper
Jose assume a pair of functions that
satisfy Rock door injectable property
and adaptable Hardware property which I
explained later
so the the construction is as follows
generates a pair of products and pair of
functions product is kept secret and
these F0 and F1 are sent to the true
approval generates this Quantum State
and measures the third register in the
computational basis
a state after the measure is this state
where X 0 and X1 are pre-images of F0
and F1 respectively
the approval sends the measurement
result y to the purifier
and the verifier sends a single bit of C
which is the challenge repeat
the approval if she equal 0 the pluriba
measures this state in the computational
basis and Returns the measurement result
the verifier because the verifier has
the truck driver she can compute x 0 and
X1 so she checks whether this is correct
one if this is correct then the verify
your accepts
foreign basis
and since the measurement result to the
Amplified
the verifier checks whether this
property is satisfied one if this is
satisfied the verifier accepts otherwise
the purifier Rejects
the completeness is very clear
select me I explained the soundness a
soundness is intuitively shown in the
following way
so assure that the classical polynomial
time probability can correctly answer
both these are challenges
then because these are bigger is crucial
we can rewind these others so this means
that first we learn this algorithms and
then we input this SQL zero to this
problem the Intruder Auto puts this
value and then we rewind the approval
before this step and then we input this
c equal C is equal to 1 to this problem
the improved array how to put this
so this means that classical approval
can output both this and this but the
Assumption of the Adaptive Hardware
property are prohibits this
so uh because of this assumption uh
Crush
cannot uh
make the verifier accept with a
non-negligible problem
so this principle quantums uh was
recently improved by this beta
so they assume a drop door they assume
some function f which is trapdoor and
221 Collision resistant hash
so in this assumption they no longer
require the Adaptive hardcore with
property
so their construction is as follows the
verifier generates a pair of trapdoor
and function f and drop door is kept
secret the purifier sends only the
function f to the plural
approval generates this Quantum State
and measures the second register in the
computational basis
the state after the measurement is this
state
where x0 and X1 are two different images
of this are f
that's approval sent the measurement
result y to the verifier
then the verifier sends a single bit of
C which is a challenge beat and also a
random bit of story R to the global
if C equals 0 the probability measures
this state in the computational basis
and returns a result to the verify
because verify your uh knows the truck
driver can compute x0 and X1 and verify
your accepts if x Prime is equal to x 0
or X1
uh if SQL and C is equal to 1 then uh
the probability generate this Quantum
state by using the random bit r
then the probability measures the second
register in the other value basis
the state after the measurement is this
state
the
measurement result D to the verify
then the verifier sends a certain angle
cheetah to the group and the proverb
measures this single qubit state in this
species and return the measurement
result a
and if these are D Theta and a satisfy
certain conditions then the verifier
accesses
the correctness is easy to show and the
soundness is intuitively short as
follows so because of the Collision
resistance property the approval cannot
run both x0 and X1
and this intuitively means that the
approval cannot know
what is his state so this single Cubit
of state is one of the following four
bb84 states but because the approval
does not know both x0 under X1 so he
cannot know which state he has
she knows which state the verifyer
possesses
and therefore as a grouper cannot a
cheat by sending this uh measurement
result without generating this Quantum
state
so this is an individual understanding
of the sound voice
I have explained that previous two
constructions on groups of quantities
the first construction assumed Crow free
property and the second construction
assuming Collision resistant property
so this suggests the following natural
equation
is Collision resistance really necessary
for proofs of contactless
and the main result of the present talk
is to show the answer is no
so we construct proofs of quantumness
from product or permutations
because uh block box reductions from
closure resistant touch functions to
drop the permutations are known to be
impossible our result suggests that it
is not necessary Horizon resistance is
not necessary for rules of contacts
so before explaining the details of our
results let me give two remarks so fast
most of constructions of the groups of
quantum is assume horizontal resistance
property but there is one exception so
in this paper they constructed through
subcontinence from Quantum homomorphic
encryption
encryption implies the existence of
collision resistance hash functions
however in their Quantum homomorphic
encryption they consider only specific
types of quantum operations
and we don't know whether they are a
restoricted Quantum homomorphic
encryption employee Collision resistant
touch function or not
the secondary markets are following so
we construct groups of quantumness from
drop-down permutations about our trapezo
permutation is the full domain which
means that the domain is just the
individual Story entire space open with
storage
so one natural open program is can be
removed as a full domain property
and the reason why we ask this question
is the facto factoring based
construction can be made through domain
but it is not true in general
so for example the audio-based
construction is not a free domain
so if we can remove the fluid domain
property uh maybe we could construct
groups of quantums from our i1 for
example
so now uh let me explain our
Construction
so uh the idea is based on the so-called
interactive hustle considerably
displayed
for f is a one-way permutation and let
us consider the following an interactive
protocol between our two classical
artists and or
so Iris uh chooses uh some random bit
storing HJ uh which is chosen as follows
so the first J minus one bits are all
zero and J's bit is one on the remaining
bits are uniformly chosen up to random
and this bit sorry we descend to a bob
and the Bob returns a single bit CJ and
Jose repeat this interaction from J
equal 1 to n minus 1.
then finally they get this system or
linear equations
and you can easily verify that this
system of linear equations
has two solutions y 0 and y1
and then they showed that no
probabilistic polynomial time bubble
shall find both x 0 and X1 such that
they are satisfied so x0 is the three
measured by 0 and x y is approximate the
image of one by one
so they used this idea of interesting
interactive housing for the construction
of the commitment but we use this idea
for the construction of produce all
contacts
our idea is uh executing the interactive
housing coherent
so this F is a plot door permutation and
the verifier are fast generates the pair
of dropdown and function f those are
verify your sense this uh permutation
Health to the plural bar and also sends
this random bit of story H1 to the proof
approved by generates these Quantum
States and measure the second register
in the computational basis
the state after the measurement is this
state
the approval sends the measurement
result to the verifier
generates this Quantum state from this
state
register of this Quantum state
a state after the measurement is this
state
approval returns this measurement result
she took to the verifier so they repeat
this process and finally the three bar
possesses this Quantum state where x0 is
the drainage of y 0 and X1 is a free
image of y1
and because the verifier knows she can
compute x0 and X1
and now from this uh we can just run the
protocol or
kncvy22 from this stage
and the completeness is very clear and
soundness is also easily shown
so in this Arcane she will be by 22
paper the approval cannot run both x0
and X1 at the same time because of the
Collision registers
but here instead of the Collision
resistance we can use this result which
I mentioned in the previous slide so no
probabilistic polymer time what we can
find was x0 and X1 uh that that are the
three images or y0 and y1 respectively
also instead of collision resistance we
can use this property and again uh this
uh say that both x 0 and X1 cannot be
computed by a crash variable so we can
show the soundness in a similar way as
that in this paper
finally uh so let me conclude this talk
by giving some open problems
so the first open problem is can we
remove the true domain property so as I
said our uh drop the permutations are
full domain but if we can remove the
full domain property maybe we could
construct proof of contactless from our
IO
a second open program is can we replace
the drop-down permutations with drop
down functions
and the third open program is uh can be
able to even proper
so for example can we construct groups
of contacts from one wave functions
and finally the false open program is
actually show the quantum security of
the interactive has seen
so unfortunately uh in this paper uh we
didn't show the quantum security of
Nobby because showing this Ito setup
seems to be a very challenging problem
uh but if we can show the quantum
security of this Novi protocol we have
many nice applications like content
money we model State preparations
correspond verification Quantum
computation and so on
okay so this is the end of my talk I
thank you very much for your attention
so for details please let's see this
page